first of all this is not going to be
a serious opening at all as people are
going to see
but it is inspired by the cow
and as most people know at least who
watched some of my recent videos the cow
is a setup I'm basically showing the
double cow which I don't know if this
has ever been played but the cow is a
setup like this
Knights go to G3 and B3 Bishops go to E2
and D2
I played this entitled Tuesday uh just
over a week ago and had a lot of trouble
in the opening but I still scored like
pretty well like pretty shocking result
for playing this opening every game with
both colors but I was thinking what if
instead of putting the knights on E2 and
D2 what if we put the Bishops on
D2 and E2 to start
now I'm just making random moves for
black but I I want to show the points of
why we would put the Bishops here and
maybe I'll just tell I'll I'll tell what
the point is and then I'll show how it
can happen
the idea would be
we put the Bishops here and here we put
the knights here and here
and the ultimate goal
is to get a center Pawn Cube the goal is
basically okay let's let's say black
starts controlling the center we get
something like this basically we just
wait for
the point to take
the bishop okay let's say castle
and maybe this this
and the goal is basically to get our
pawns closer to the center
and then we wait for this bishop to be
taken somehow let's say G5 here
even if the pawn takes a take take
and then the ultimate dream
is to get something like this
where we have a Central Pawn Cube
and not only that we have two pawns that
are ready to push
it involves sacrificing in this case
three minor pieces
but I thought it'd be funny to like play
an opening where the pawns are just so
centralized and if black is
materialistic
then it's hard to attack whites
it's also hard for Bach to win any
additional minor pieces
because white doesn't have any
this is a terrible opening but just the
concept of playing and opening to try
and get as many Central pawns as
possible kind of intrigued me do I dare
play this in like a a tournament
uh yeah it's definitely not for longer
chess maybe it's playable in
bullet chess
I'll have to change the stream title
because the stream title will not
reflect what is about to happen
playing my new opening let's try let's
see how many Central Pawn cues I can get
because those do translate into rows and
trophies
which maybe someday will translate into
currency maybe some social currency
okay
double playing a strong player so my
opponent also going to play the same
opening
okay okay
um
okay
oh I feel so strong right now
let's see how solid this Pawn Center
will be
wow
okay so I'm down three minor pieces but
look at my Pawns
oh they're so beautiful
this makes me so happy
oh
okay E5
okay there he goes a pawn
that was kind of an important pun too
but
fear
I have a little bit of fear
for
still down three minor pieces
ah
that's not good to blend your pawns here
play that
okay
foreign
let's go
undefeated with this opening
oh I'm so happy I got a winning position
too I just didn't have enough time
what a start
look at this opening
oh these Pawns
okay
let's see how high I can finish in this
tournament
I'm not losing all my games thankfully
yeah the cow is evolving
into some
do we call it the Giga cow
uh
do I berserk let's berserk I'll play the
opening
oops wait this is this is the opening
goal
take my Bishop yes
yes
I don't care about that night I just
care about getting Center Pawns
uh oh
Knight C4 would have been a pork
okay time for the pawns to
make some moves I'm losing this Pawn but
oppon's not punishing me
there goes Black's Pawn
that's a good move
threatening made in one
let's go look at my Pawns
oh every game brings me so much joy
I'm sorry for the people that don't like
this or don't approve of this but I'm
having fun that's what matters
okay playing a good opponent here
yeah what do I do if my point like
doesn't take anything
you just wait
maybe play a crab
um yeah this is not going according to
plan but
okay some new opening theory in
developing here
trying to take the knights
um bong cloud
[Music]
there
hmm
soccer Exchange
ah that doesn't there
I've messed up a little bit
maybe not too much though
okay
some hope
I'm down two Bishops
and a little bit of time
now soon to be one Bishop
wow look at these Pawns
yeah it's all about the pawn play
down two Bishops but
oh Queens with Chuck
let's go okay my pawns were dissolving
but not quickly enough there
okay
I've yet to lose a game
50 third place six tournament points
is working
cowabunga
apone's ready to like take my thing
sneaky threats
okay opening strategy is changing a
little bit
and queen's about to get trapped
look at this move
uh let's play this
I want to keep my knight
hmm
12 seconds
duh my queen
two seconds
okay let's go
oh
let's go
okay no berserking this game
the nice thing is like I can just
automatically play these moves
openings predetermined
I don't care about material
I care about my queen though
finding this Pawn
yeah so my b-pawn turned to a d-pawn
I sacrificed two pieces to make that
happen
yeah white doesn't know how to crack my
my creature
getting a big time Advantage here
I'll offer The Rook trade
okay this is what we want to see
pawns are coming closer to the center
and now I want to bring my knight to E5
so I can have a a pawn Cube
if I want to allow Bishop G6
there we go
these pawns are so magnificent
I'm down two minor pieces
okay
start of the YMCA
okay one on time there
hmm
I don't think I'm gonna win the
tournaments but
maybe I can
finish top 10.
oops I didn't mean to repeat but okay I
drew someone rated 2400 with this
opening
oh I should have played for a win
I only meant to repeat repeat twice but
that's okay
still undefeated
[Music]
so what do people want to name this
buffalo buffalo is a nice name
bull Giga cow
okay let's keep going
yeah I'm realizing the Rook is nicely
placed on G1
the file opens up so often
oh I haven't even sacked any pieces to
get this structure
let's move back
okay maybe
this
select hpong
I don't think I want to lose a knight
items like black didn't take it let's
just take that phone
a nice little shelter for my king
take that
um
this is a free Pawn
oh that's annoying
let's play this
I just trap the bishop
Bishop was almost it's not quite trapped
it's almost trapped okay I win the
bishop
a little bit quicker
go
that was a very temporary Pawn diamond
pawns are too strong there
or the Mad Cow mad cow is actually a
pretty good name
all right
to mentally prepare
I'll probably knows what I'm doing
so I'm down two minor pieces
nice thing here white has no Center
Pawns
okay socks it back a piece
a good move
okay I'm sacking the piece for the the
pawn Center
down two minor pieces now
this is actually kind of fascinating and
before I moved back
um
foreign
whatever this is
okay 36 minutes left wow there's gonna
be a lot of a lot more of this to come
playing the top seed
um
I mean this opponent's rating is higher
than nine
I feel like I should not be doing this
and let's play this
okay at least I'm getting what I want
I really really want
okay only down the piece
yeah I'm under the palm
okay
even even the strong player is having a
hard time dealing with my Pawn Center
um let's play this
Pawn Diamond achieved
equal material achieved
vaccinating that
a material now
I think made in one let's go oh this is
the highest rated player I've defeated
tournament leader to well the game
okay
13th Place
there we go
if I can defeat the tournament leader I
have hope to
to meet you in the tournaments but
it's gonna be a struggle people are
probably catching on to what I'm doing
yeah there goes one Bishop
I see four
have to take
because
it's a slightly uglier Pawn structure
than usual
can I not defend
I can take
I have to play G4
it's not gonna
check
okay that's a free Pawn Rook H1 maybe
coming
uh
some hope
a little bit of Hope
I'm gonna shut out the bishop
very key move
aha now I have this move
okay winning position
opponents should have been winning there
okay got the got the victory
what a game top 10.
15 points are the first
2100 is in first wow
doing the berserking strategy
if I play someone in Sub 2000 maybe I
berserk
playing first place now
mad can interesting argument saying the
center pawns are much better than the
material sacrificed also it confuses
your opponents it does
highly confusing
things for that Amber
okay so I saw the H Pawn I want the
queen side Castle
[Music]
um
do this move first
this
yeah look at these files
um Queen's out of play
this
okay I've stacked two minor pieces
I'm gonna play this
could have been the queen
maybe this first
Save The Rook
let's go
and defeated another high rated player
top 10.
okay nobody's working this game
I'm getting a feel for it
like my first few games were a little
bit Rocky but now I'm totally okay like
giving up material like this
all right let's play this
okay we're thinking 18 moves let's go
gave up all my minor pieces there
yeah this is a mad cow or the Buffalo or
the Bison
or the Giga cow
sixth place ten points out of the first
guy that showed this to Anna crowling
yeah I mean it's it's a very bad opening
objectively but this is just so much fun
at least for bullet chess
There Goes My H pong
um let's play A5
okay this is what I want
nice Pawn formation
um
I'll just sack the knights
have another Center Pawn now
how's my night doing on B2
opponents playing wisely
to close down the center
I don't know what to do here
it's just sack the knights
it's probably not great for me
now in three minor pieces again
but look at my Pawns
now I'm down only two minor pieces I
still got pawns have to defend the Rook
Queen defends everything
including my king
okay let's start winning things
oh I didn't see that move
just took out my pawns though
pawns are crucial for the end game
that was a mistake
every Pawn is a potential Queen
okay
what a finish thank you for news thank
you dinky Daffy
yeah if you're just tuning in this is
different different opening content than
usual
okay
ah novelty
um
I'm not sure what to do here let's just
push Pawns
it's getting interesting
H6
play this first
ah
positions crumbling a little bit
oh that's mate what to do okay let's
move on thank you Iceman
yeah I'm playing stronger opponents here
it's not easy
at least I'll get the time advantage
and upon Center again
I was threatening made in one
could have been really nice
okay
got my Center Pawn Cube
uh this
King found some shelter
so I'm down three minor pieces but I'm
up time and I have a
have four standard pawns to zero Center
Pawns
I just want a knight and this Bishop's
hanging
just one another Bishop
long live the center Pawn Cube
hmm
how do I Advance though
hit this
we got three of the threats
look at this Pawn chain
it's like a snake
uh let's keep advancing
let's go okay
got the clutch dirty flag
oh that was a funny end game
down the bishop but had the center point
you for us
okay I don't think I'll be winning the
tournament but I think I'm having the
most fun
I'll try and finish top five would be
like a nice result
got 21 minutes left of this
oh
um that was not
expected
okay
I guess I'm just allowing Pawn takes
Bishop
There Goes My a pawn
can I trap The Rook
at least hug The Rook momentarily
yeah not a great position here
and try and work with it
dope I hung a queen
yeah this might be too much to come back
from
what to do okay not my proudest game
there
uh
okay let's recover oh this person again
okay I beat this person earlier with
this opening
see if they've learned their lesson
um
yeah I think they learned their lesson
this is so uncomfortable
I'm down two minor pieces
and down on time which is not great
but my pawns are smiling
oh no my Smiley Pawns
oh no my thing
God I pray for his stalemate
it was actually kind of close to sell me
it there
close again
opponent confused
King was very slippery there
uh hold on until The Bitter End
okay still top ten
so what are we calling this has there
been a
um a conclusion
mad cow
okay let's try and redeem
redeem myself for what just happened
okay
um
Knight G3
okay achieving I just plunder the pawn
stocking pieces
probably for good reason
so I'm only down a bunch of Pawns
H6 confusing move
I'm down three pawns here
the opponent's burning a lot of time
play this
oh no my knight
okay this is something
but is it actually something
um
yeah lack is actually really safe here
to use a clock
ah a little bit slow what to do
okay top 10 will be like a very
successful result
here we go
because yeah opponents are getting
stronger
oh this is the opponent who plays the
London
maybe I just don't sacrifice pieces
let's try and win pieces
um
still go for some creative ideas
oh
I take
foreign
so I have the battery I have
actually have a lot of attacking
potential
F3 probably coming
E4 I fork
okay time to consume some Pawns
do I still have casting rights
I don't remember
I maybe can find out shortly
or maybe not mate next move
okay
did I ever move the king or Rook
no I didn't I I still could have castled
in the final position
but Checkmate was Stronger
all right
so 10th place it's berserk
trying not to waste any time
yeah I feel like I'm wasting time
my queen just got trapped too
okay so Queen odds and time odds
um
my pawns aren't as magnificent as they
should be
okay now there's slightly more
magnificent
I'll use my G file
there we go this is something
I'm still down the queen but
I have a potential future Queen
Rook
yeah do this
there goes box Queen
where's my mate
let's go okay
oh what a game
holy holy mad cow
[Music]
okay we're moving on
still top ten barely
got the berserking points there
I don't want to berserk this player
so I think the plan is to play a four
just sack the pawn and just get the Rook
to the king side
this is a very a very non-materialistic
opening
um
[Music]
I just sack like this
and Knight takes Pawn that would be neat
the pawn
I think I have to take
so I'm down bishop and Rook but I have
amazing structure that's what matters
play this
my king is actually kind of safe
oh but my position's crumbling
still some hope
this tell me I saw it coming a split
second before it happened
okay
let's go
yeah the tricks are getting stalemated
when the opponent's using two queens you
don't want to have the Queens be giving
checks
okay let's use this idea
hmm
okay I still have three Center Pawns
down a piece I did berserk so I should
move a little bit quicker
almost mating now
not quite though
but almost
I mean threatening Queen A7
Rook here I take the Rook
that's a good move
so close to Nate
there we go I had to calculate that my
opponent's time you moves prior
okay still top ten
thank you scarred
morphe would have loved this not sure
about that
maybe though
I'm just waiting for black to take the
bishop which blocks not to or whites
White's not doing
ah this is not what I wanted
a double flame pawns are not the the
strategy behind this opening
oh no my knight
threatening Queen G2 checkmate
what a funny idea
I guess we're just Trading
ah this is not good
in this
um
I was happy a moment ago
opponent doesn't want to trade Queens
probably for good reason
oh
uh I had a little bit of Hope there
what to do 11th Place okay
to
finish strong
I could have had a streak there too
was this
was my my queen wants to get to A1
okay
[Music]
um
sacking the thing
I should have played Pawn C3
What's Happening Here
oh that was a king H7 was probably the
worst move in the position okay
I'll take it though
hey Ninth Place
I think there's time for probably one
more game that will count for the
tournament
maybe two more if I berserk
okay
opponent's probably not berserking back
oh there we go okay
okay let's take with pieces so I got the
Pawns
Dal
ew
I was dreaming of checkmates
okay that's a nice gift
on passant
here we go
five seconds
oh
oh it's hard to mate with Knight and
Bishop when having less than the seconds
oh it's a do okay
waiting for the planet to observe back I
don't think it's happening so
okay wish me luck
final game not sure if this will count
for the tournament but
might count for something
okay
this is what I want
oh that's not what I want
really not what I want
oh no my Giga cow
there's a little
okay
oh I lost some reading there but
okay that was an experiment
okay
well that was fun if this goes on
YouTube uh
let me know what you think in the
comments